the silver lining is sometimes the
presser their own worst enemy sometimes
the press undercut their own argument
and I saw this on the Today Show on NBC
they were doing a segment on The Today
Show on the Gerber baby right this is so
such a soft fluffy segment how could
this have national political import NBC
News the the whole left-wing media
apparatus right completely gung-ho
behind abortion always talking about
abortion is women's health care women's
rights the war on women if you ever try
to protect little babies so they do a
segment on the Gerber baby no big deal
and you have a family that has this
adopted baby so the new Gerber baby is
this little black girl and the family is
a white family so it's pretty pretty
clear from the outset that the baby is
adopted and I guess NBC just didn't
think about the implications of doing a
story that's all focused on adoption
listen to the way that NBC allows a
wonderful pro-life message to get out on
network television
Courtney you entered magnolias into the
running because your family's story is a
really important one that you wanted to
share can you explain why that is they
chose her life they sent her on this
incredible journey today and what was
happening yeah oh what a great story if
NBC only knew that this was the way it
was going to go they never would have
aired it right because right now with
the left is trying to do is push a
message of racial division based on
sensationalizing a sad local story and
trying to pretend that this has
implications for the broader politics
that were in some sort of epidemic of
racial killing of white guys racist
White's killing black guys hunting them
down on the street you know basically
they're just hiding their Klan who it's
right and this is not borne out by the
statistics it is not happening but
that's the story they're trying to do
because they want to keep Americans
divided and angry and focused on things
that let them off the hook and then they
accidentally allow this story through
which is a story of wonderful racial
harmony right of adoption of coming
together the story of the adoptive
parents speaking to the biological
parents and having them involved in a
way to say look if you chose life for
your kid and look at what a great life
your kid gets and the kid is like very
cute baby obviously you know it's being
selected as the Gerber baby and she's
there like bop bop bop bop you know and
it's very very heartwarming to watch
this the news doesn't like to let too
many of those stories get through
particularly when it undercuts the
narratives they're making about Society
and the arguments that they're making
about the value of human life but every
so often often through the media's own
incompetence one of those stories sneaks
through and you begin to see the truth
about the country
[Music]
[Music]